leroy bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors depuis l'arrivée
de l'administration weiden l'europe et
en particulier l'ukraine est elle
redevenue le théâtre d'une nouvelle
guerre froide entre les états unis et la
russie
cela semble évident donc l'ukraine et la
la zone chaude qui préoccupent le monde
aujourd'hui c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire même si depuis quelques jours donc
qu'ils sont bien passées pour savoir que
le il ya une tentative de détournement
d'attention vers un autre pays proche de
la russie qui est le kazakhstan mais il
est clair que nous sommes face à une
situation extrêmement dangereuse où
manifestement l'otan et ses alliés font
tout pour tenter de déstabiliser la
russie américains et russes qui parle de
l'ukraine sont les européens pourquoi
finalement le sort de l'europe se
dessine-t-il sans eux
mais je pense que la russie a compris
depuis longtemps maintenant que l'europe
n'était que l'union européenne en tout
cas n'était que le
petit caniche en quelque sorte des
américains et de l'otan et qu'il ne fait
rien de parler à madame ursula von der
leyen ni même à monsieur maquereau ou à
son homologue allemand le dans la mesure
où ceux-ci ne font que entériner les
décisions de l'otan donc les russes
étant des gens pragmatiques et réalistes
ont bien fini par comprendre que l'union
européenne n'avait aucune capacité
décisionnelle et qu' il valait mieux
s'adresser au mont dieu qu'à ses saints
et le ch est la raison pour laquelle
donc la russie a demandé exclusivement
d'avoir des relations avec l'hymne des
américains et l'otan et à ce sujet
j'ajouterai d'ailleurs que en ce qui
concerne la réunion d'aujourd'hui à
genève je pense que très clairement a
rien de spectaculaire ne ressortira
parce qu'il est évident que les
américains ne pourront pas reconnaître
de l'or lors des fêtes et faire d'un
moindre concession publique du bien
public parce que je suis à peu près
convaincu il y aura des concessions qui
seront faites mais celles-ci seront
faites après une réunion beaucoup plus
importante qui aura dû après demain à
bruxelles cette fois ci entre la russie
et l'otan et il ne faut pas oublier que
dans ce domaine là les russes ont
demandé à ce que des leurs homologues
militaires de haut niveau soit présent à
cet entretien de bruxelles ce qui
signifie que c'est véritablement là se
jouera le l'enjeu de ces négociations
entre les russes et les américains une
semaine diplomatique à haut risque donc
avec ces différentes rencontres vous
l'avez dit le sommet américano russes
qui va être suivie d'une réunion russie
otan puis russie au sc eux et les deux
parties campent sur leurs positions
alors on se souvient que lors du
rattachement de la crimée à la russie
les menaces des européens n'avaient eu
que peu d'effet pensez vous que vladimir
poutine prenne réellement au sérieux
l'occident
lui et moi mais là j'ai mis quelques
heures de son donc je n'ai pas entendu
la question c'est depuis la loge des
couleurs du rattachement de la crimée à
la russie les menaces des européens
n'avaient eu que peu d'effet en fait sur
la russie est ce que vous pensez que
vladimir poutine prenne réellement au
sérieux l'occident aujourd'hui
manifestement non puisque donc il est
clair que la politique de sanctions
aussi bien de la part des américains que
des européens n'a pas eu d'impact notre
père pas l'impact qu'il était attendu
contre la russie puisque bien au
contraire donc la russie a augmenté son
niveau d'eau torchis de capacité de
résilience grâce à cette politique de
sanctions donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui
la pour les russes la coupe est pleine
et que les menaces de sanctions y
compris gravissime comme celle qui
consisterait à couper la russie du
réseau swift de relations interbancaires
même ce genre de menace aujourd'hui ne
batte un pue la russie qui est prête
compte tenu de la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes qui est prêt à
franchir le rubicon pour empêcher le
temps d'une seule chine en taux de
continuer à me lasser leur pays vladimir
poutine qui est ouvert au dialogue qui
veut trouver une issue à cette crise
craignent n en dialoguant avec avec
justement les américains mais également
les européens le tord affirme que le
risque d'un conflit et rés est ce que
vous êtes pessimiste également d'écouter
patron pas trop parce que heureusement
parce que je pense que la russie a écrit
merci réussi à
réinventer des armes qui en est la
guerre la russie a montré depuis au
moins 2013 qu'elle était détenteur de
capacité
intermédiaire électronique qui empêche
littéralement l'occident d'utiliser ses
armes de destruction massive et de ce
point de vue là je pense qu elles une
volonté depuis le mois d'avril en
ukraine notamment de lancer l'armée
ukrainienne
contre la russie contre le dos nu contre
le dopage mais de manière très claire
elle n'y a pas n'a pas été en mesure de
le faire grâce au contre mesures
électroniques que la russie a déployé je
pense que c'est pour cela heureusement
que la guerre ne pourra pas de déclarer
en tout cas pas de manière
traditionnelle en tout cas donc pas avec
des forces conventionnelles en revanche
il y est toujours possible que
des six responsables ont atteint ou
ailleurs
tout en exhorant chishan le feu
nucléaire du moins l'ordre de nice ils
ont tenté de forcer la main à la russie
pour entrer dans le bon sens parce que
manifestement les faucons du pentagone
ne sont intéressés que par une chose
c'est que la russie entend guerre contre
l'ukraine et tous les moyens seront bons
pour cela mais je pense qu'on part une
fois la russie a la capacité d'empêcher
tout déclenchement d'une guerre 1 contre
elle merci beaucoup en tout cas pour
votre analyse emmanuel leroy je rappelle
que vous êtes président de l'institut